yeah welcome to this video playing f
drive after I've let's play if I've come
on after I from the Ukraine right you
you non your flex iam that's obviously
be Sam yeah c'mon let's to Bishop e7
there should be seven is actually the a
bit more aggressive move then Bishop c5
I know this sounds weird but it's um it
keeps more pieces on the board Bishop c5
very often these two exchanges uh huh
interesting 93 yeah I was what I was
preparing is actually at five it's a
it's a bit of a sick idea that down it's
something that I've played for a while
and blitz chess and it's working okay
for me preparing f5 was king h eight and
nine th but he played a good response
opening up the position like that is is
actually a good good way to deal with it
and the night takes or just pawn takes
e5 this problem yeah what is not g8
doing okay I'm not claiming that this is
too great what I'm doing
hmm yeah it's probably a probably just a
bit better for white he he he reacted in
the correct correct way f5s probably
just rather suicidal thing to play
probably need to be M be content with
the small Museum yeah this is Sam not
nice yeah
yeah white is some substantially better
him to bishops and just a big advantage
in space
why there should be six ever death not
much that I can do okay this King h8
maneuver really failed at this game play
ff4 and push a g4 but where else
maybe I can exchange one payoff Bishop
cm okay this is a slightly helping me at
least then I have a natural defense for
the deep on now with the rupiah on the
eight and the Queen it's a it's of
course not very inspiring but maybe it's
it's it's playable this thing is also
coming back to life okay Saudi 54 and
it's just improve this a little bit of
this position yeah I don't know he's
expanding but this is also weakening
some somewhat
mm okay
hmm can I get some counter play against
the King here yeah maybe maybe this way
somehow getting closer to the King does
you want to play your five I really
don't get it so exchange this I'm not
sure this was good ah 97 I think was a
mistake the matter will be six is
actually a bad piece and it was the best
bit decision I mean shouldn't have
exchanged the night
ideas Queen d8 now you can play Bishop
g4 but I can just go back it's it's
fairly solid I don't think he can do so
much
yeah I need to get some play quickly
here but them still that's no threat at
the moment and then I'm having this idea
of playing d4 and then g6 getting rid of
the bishop
maybe this isn't so bad the night on a
fate is doing a good defense job and
he's very this is often a problem white
is better with the space advantage but
you have advanced all your pawns and you
have lots of weaknesses in your camp the
whole third rank for example g3 as
everything's week and if my pieces are
able to get into the position okay Queen
h3 so interesting idea mmm interesting
maybe it's also good yeah Queen a three
Queen h3 and this is this looks really
sick now but
and this was strong move Jeff form
this I didn't understand
yeah I don't think he has enough now
threatening look aged six now we need
the Queen here we go cannot take this is
check on YouTube
you pulled it maybe you need to play 35
I don't know check
need to take quickly here to to not risk
any time time issues like okay check me
yeah this was some really bitter game
for whitey he really wasn't controlling
all the time I'm an unjust and setting
up a DVD fancy and hope to hold on so
maybe this was this was I think a
mistake actually to exchange this night
he should I think take just take and to
keep his position a bit more flexible
despondent be successes it's more
weakness then the strength that this
didn't help much to smooth but I didn't
see Bishop it it's our Bishop f5
character t5 and do this was interesting
probably it's simply grateful white
computer gives wide the substantial or
not so substantial advantage and now
this is winning okay yeah II five wins
okay yeah it's no surprise I mean look
at the position he really am I'll play
me here I can i can probably defend much
better but this this is terrible he sees
certainly a miscalculated something him
okay yeah here can play but should be
six which is which is very easy drawn at
least like this and I cannot play for
witnesses still trapping the Queen but
you can do this and I
yeah this is it cubes made me so back
and just the draw and in the game you
just say just blended the Queen after
this but now black is winning already
this threat is so Becky we can only play
that to avoid it but then I'm I'm coming
coming with the deep on this is winning
yeah but did lucky was very very worst
in this game yeah thanks for watching